it's lunchtime
so i've been at the farm about a week
now and i've joined the regular routine
of the farm
which means i'm getting up at 4 00 a.m
to help milk the cows
and i want to talk a little bit more
about what that process is because
the milking equipment that i showed last
time that's really just the end of the
process and there's
a bit more to it so i show up at 4am and
the first thing that we do is we
herd all the cows down to milking collar
which is down that ramp behind me
and it's kind of like getting the cows
out of bed because they're all in their
stalls and they're lying down
and they don't necessarily want to go
get milked
so you sort of walk up behind them and
you whistle at them and let them know
it's time to get up
and you you come and you walk in if
they're not getting up
and uh pat them on the path on the back
and eventually they get the message and
they're hurt animals so they know where
they're going and uh they head down the
ramp we close the gate behind them
and then that's the chance to clean the
stalls so i'm going to show you how to
clean a stall
so it's a pretty simple process we're
just breaking the cow pies out of the
stalls and sometimes there's
urine or milk that has puddled up and we
pull that out too
and we pull it away from the edges of
the stalls because if we leave it there
um the cow's tails hang over the edge of
the stalls and
they will get covered with cow poop
so just keeping it clean like that and
then
we cover it up with a bed of shavings
that will help absorb any liquids
and move on to the next stall so it's a
pretty simple process
and it kind of makes me think taking
care of cows is a little bit like taking
care of two year olds
so we take care of 122 year olds every
morning
and it's not that complicated we're just
taking care of their basic needs
we're giving them food and we're
cleaning up their poop and making sure
their poop doesn't get in their food
and because they're not toilet trained
there needs to be a system to make sure
that the poop doesn't get in the food
and that system is basically built into
the design of the barn
as you can see the food is down the
outside of the barn and this bar here is
preventing the cows from getting through
and
stepping in their food and pooping in
their food
so the food stays on this side and the
poop stays on that side
but we can't leave the poop there
because it would just pile up
so the barn has a poop removal system
built into it that
is actually pretty ingenious and it's
certainly better than shoveling poop
into carts and
taking it away somewhere else so the
barn is set up so that
most of the pooping happens in the
aisles between the stalls and when we're
cleaning the stalls we're basically just
raking the poop into the aisles
and then these automated wipers come
down the aisles a couple times a day on
chains
and push all the poop into the drains
and there's basically a sewage channel
that runs all the way down the length of
the barn
and it comes out here and it doesn't
stop here
it actually flows down the hill to this
manure tank and then a couple times a
year robert will drive up to the manure
tank
he'll fill up his manure spreader out of
the tank and he'll go and spread manure
on his fields
so that's how goes down here at the
dairy farm i've got something special
for you next week
i got to film a calf being born and it
just melted my heart
so you can tune into that next week by
subscribing to the youtube channel
um you can learn more about the
documentary that i'm making at
the hands that feed us dot ca or you can
follow me on facebook and instagram
and tune in next week for that calf